Thank You Colin and Jim Mackay no film
archive is an extraordinarily rich and
promising resource for research in east
asian film you can see by looking at the
list of papers to be presented today
just how rich and and and what a broad
range it covers with papers on China and
Korea as well as Japan and on a wide
range of topics on japanese film i think
you can get still a further notion of
this actually if you look at what some
of you may have looked at another's not
the present draft of the of the
arrangement list for the Maquis no
collection just peeing out a few items
at random director files critic files
film production company files from film
studios scenarios 1923 to 1990 post-war
magazines pre-war magazines movie
theater handbills photos and posters
audio-visual materials old and new film
book and a whole series of subject files
on amateur and small gauge films
animated film and comics pre-war arch
censorship 1908 to 1994 film
organizations music song books film
school textbooks and shooting techniques
proletarian film psychology theatre
wartime materials World's Fair materials
is a collection of just extraordinary
range variety and richness that we are
amazingly privileged to have with us in
the star library and available to the
faculty of east asian languages and
cultures my department but to faculty
across the university and to faculty
from other institutions as well i'm
going to repeat some of Paul Andrews
thanks but this time on behalf of my
department East Asian languages and
cultures just to pick out a few of the
individuals that Paul has already
thanked obviously of course our thanks
should go first of all to a man that I
had hoped to be able to meet today I've
never had the privilege of meeting
Mackey Noma motive himself for as Paul
says his obsession
and his vision in assembling this
collection over a period of decades next
I want to thank in particular my good
friend Amy Hinrich who took the
initiative who saw that this could
happen who persuaded the central library
that it could and should happen and who
solicited and received the initial
donation of 250 thousand dollars from
Donald keen amy is to be saluted for her
vision her persistence her hard work in
making this begin to happen and making
it happen truly and also to jim cheung
who picked up the ball and ran with it
showing the energy and vigor and Verve
that he has shown from the moment he
arrived to us at columbia putting the
weight of star library's energy and
resources behind the processing of the
collection and it's used by scholars to
jim Neil and Damon Jagger's for having
the vision themselves to see how
valuable this collection could be and
for lending the library's full support
to its acquisition and cataloging etc to
Donald keen himself did I already say
for his characteristic generosity let's
let's face it in specifically the
generous donation of the $250,000 that
led on to the funding of this collection
to Beth chats off Makino archivist for
the hands-on work of the processing
cataloging maintaining and making the
collection accessible to scholars here
and elsewhere in the world and finally
and most importantly for the moment
we're at today to Paul and ER and tecate
holy for the rich and hard intellectual
work of organizing this extraordinary
symposium that demonstrates precisely
the range of uses to which these
materials can be put and the richness
that they afford to scholars so thank
you on behalf of east asian languages
and cultures to all of these people
thank you